Before we get to the news,
Donald Trump gave
a press conference
right before we started taping,
which means it's time
for "Breaking Crazy."
♪♪
President Trump this afternoon
gave a press conference
that can only be described
as clinically insane.
You know that list
of side effects
at the end
of a pharmaceutical ad?
He apparently has all of them.
[ Laughter ]
He said among other things
that there were very fine people
on both sides of the events
of Charlottesville.
He asked if people on the left
have any guilt
that the white supremacists
became violent,
and then he said this...
-Many of those people were
there to protest the taking down
of the statue of Robert E. Lee,
so this week it's Robert E. Lee.
I notice that
Stonewall Jackson's coming down.
I wonder, is it
George Washington next week?
And is it Thomas Jefferson
the week after?
You know, you really do have
to ask yourself,
where does it stop?
-Where does it stop?
Buddy, we've been asking
ourselves that question
since January.
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]
Normally when someone is talking
that level of crazy,
Batman crashes through
the ceiling and punches him.
[ Laughter ]
Trump is like a bad waitress
in a crappy diner
who's trying to get fired
so she can go to a concert.
[ Laughter ]
Here's a picture of
General John Kelly,
his new Chief of Staff,
during this press conference.
[ Laughter ]
Look at that guy. Trump is
so fully out of his mind,
he broke a general.
[ Laughter ]
That guy's been in wars.
Congress, isn't this enough?
Cut bait on the President.
It's time to let this
crazy bitch go to the concert.
This has been "Breaking Crazy."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Applause continues ]